cette vidéo enregistrée par les caméras
de surveillance
l'homme en actions organisant dans la
nuit de dimanche à lundi
la destruction de ces scooters de mer
sous la plaque de pont café à sainte
luce est en ce moment
activement recherché par les autorités
déjà en 2018
la société jet adventure avait fait
l'objet d'actes de vandalisme
aujourd'hui encore les salariés ne
cachent pas leur émotion c'est un choc
moi je vous avoue qu en arrivant ce
matin on avait encore les relents d les
relents les odeurs de l' incendie
franchement là et pas envie d'être qui
cet emplacement idéal
situé à quelques mètres de l'hôtel
fréquenté semble faire l'objet d'une
très grande convoitise
elle a vu se succéder plusieurs sociétés
sous plusieurs formes génétiques
depuis l'année dernière la ss jane
adventures exploits de cet espace une
base nautique a créé par les affaires
maritimes
les responsables ne cachent pas qu'ils
réalisent un chiffre d'affaires très
intéressant autant d'éléments qui
pourraient justifier les tentatives de
déstabilisation
une place qui était convoité par
plusieurs par plusieurs personnes deux
trois personnes éventuellement bon après
il y en a un qui l'a eu
ben les autres désolé de vous dire ça
mais au jeu bien vous avez perdu
par contre derrière c'est à nos familles
il ya ma vie tous les jours suite à une
plainte enregistrée par la gendarmerie
de rivière-pilote ce matin un technicien
en investigation criminelle procédaient
aux prélèvements d'usagé s'ils enquête
est en cours
en parallèle le responsable de cette
entreprise offre une récompense à toute
personne qui pourrait permettre
d'identifier l'auteur de cet acte si
dans tout de même que son préjudice est
estimé à plus de 80000 euros